all right new role now that America has
helped the rest of the world address the
problems at FIFA it has to help the rest
of the world address an even bigger
world problem speedos on their beaches
here's how it's going to work if there
are too many speedos on your beaches
this summer sanctions will be drawn up
and enforced but if you combine a speedo
with gold chains we invade their oh now
that Dennis Hastert can be added to the
list of those who pushed through the
impeachment of Bill Clinton then later
got busted for their own sex scandals
along with Newt Gingrich Bob Livingston
and we hide for now on the 4th among the
impeachable maybe you could be in that
one too neuro Cameron Crowe doesn't have
to apologize for casting Emma Stone as
an Asian in his new movie there's
nothing inherently racist about having a
white person play an Asian just ask
Jerry Lewis and Mickey Rooney
new rule if you're banning pigeon
breeding as Isis did because the sight
of the genitalia as they fly overhead is
offensive to Islam you've got bigger
problems in the infidel pigeons are
harmless and take flight the moment
they're startled no wait that's the
Iraqi army either way why not embrace
the more obvious rational solution
fitting the pigeons with tiny little
pigeon burka
Nero someone has to pull Chris Christie
a sucker
someone has to pull Chris Christie aside
and tell him the lap-band goes on the
inside this is a real picture of
something chris Christie did sober and
on purpose this week at a charity event
a charity event to turn women into
lesbian Sammy Sosa meet Sammy sofa
hey make fun of how Christie looks all
you want he did hit a double and it's
nice to hear about a conservative
getting to second base this week besides
Josh Duggar anyway